gabriel et j'ai un problème je ne peux
pas résister une femme en tant
qu'honnête indécis ouais j'en connait
enfin quelques ginko normale était là
depuis qu'on est rentré en france un peu
compliqué on a perdu tous les contacts
attention nous on a des copies notion on
en connaît en san francisco plein la
rolls cloud et la grande la grande vous
appelle un grand nombre d'accords les
quatre là bas vous avez un
agrandissement des meufs à san francisco
gabriel et j'ai un problème je ne peux
pas résister une femme je bossais sur
des briques à moi septembre et que ne
pas résister aux femmes c'est le
problème de 90% la population masculine
comment comptez vous gérer votre
relation avec moi plus pas vous le
cacher les jolie brune au regard
pétillant et au chenil enchaîné mais
aussi pourquoi pas enchaîner poursuivi
alors on va mettre les choses au clair
déjà les hommes qui souffrent de votre
pathologie s'imagine toujours que toutes
les femmes veulent coucher avec eux et
puis sans vouloir vous vexer vous avez
un sourire un peu niais voilà celui là